cette bâtisse à l'abandon dans la
municipalité de franquelin près de la
frontière américaine
c'est l'institut d'aurea ou ce qu'il en
reste des orphelins de duplessis y ont
séjourné à l'abri des regards
subissant des sévices physiques et
psychologiques
c'est peut-être le seul endroit que marc
boudreau n'a pas connu bas noté depuis
sa naissance d'une institution
psychiatrique à l'autre à huberdeau à la
barbe à l'alberta l'est el kahlaoui à
des prix réduits d'autres malwares de
shopping ce type d électrochoc et la
camisole de force vise à louey
j'ai perdu une caméra n'a cessé east un
long barrage de vie de sa voix ne
suivent toujours toujours toujours cela
ils sont des centaines comme lui qui ont
été abandonnées et qui se sont retrouvés
dans des instituts dirigé par des
congrégations religieuses
ils étaient déclarés malades mentaux
c'était la façon d'obtenir plus d'argent
du fédéral
ils ne s'en sont pas remis las après
fred j'ai su je ne pas continuer à
changer mon lieu de chair là qu'est ce
que j'ai subi celle tech jojo sharp
obame est toujours chaud et puis c'est
au tour de -6 puis j'ai ma campagne mais
pas la décevoir mais je réfléchis je
planche malheureux c'est des copies
originales de la police le rapport le
soc et gaston séguin qui demandait à
longueuil depuis 25 ans votent viennot
accumule les dossiers il a décidé
d'aider les orphelins de duplessis
depuis qu'il a appris que sa femme
claire duguay avait subi le même sort à
la mort de sa mère son père a été
contraint de la place et elle s'est
retrouvée coup sur coup à l'hôpital de
saint ferdinand d'halifax et ensuite à
rimouski place et faussement arriéré
mental profonde grand père paternel
alcoolique
c'est pas vrai non mais c'est ça tu vois
les flèches que j'ai mis mes meilleures
marques dassin michel d'arcangues et ses
frères et soeurs derrière des mois et
c'était pas vrai que je n'aime pas qui
ont sali là ma famille y opposer ma vie
j'ai pas de bon ça c'était heureuse avec
mes parents ne veut pas d'un pinceau le
curé d'huile album france va envoyer
dans une classe de m il dit qu on
identifie pour ce faire instruire jamais
instruit madame c'était magané après
toutes ces années elle est encore
terrorisés car oui j'ai toujours preuve
j'étais vivant au dessus le drame n'est
venu me chercher c'est quoi je fais là
vous avez encore peur bonjour au
dépanneur d'activia me chercher de
quiberon fait un point d'eau j'ai pas du
tout mon cas mais j'ai 81 alors je te
reconnais dans adam west affaires
naulleau je passe autour de soi maillot
là j'ai pas madame vous jure je sais
l'avocat alan stein qui a accepté de les
défendre
celui là même qui a gagné sa cause pour
les victimes du docteur cameron à
l'hôpital royal victoria
pour lui le cas des orphelins de
duplessis et pire on a fait des
expériences aussi ou exact exactement et
en anglais on peut dire des yeux et des
voies used by pix c'est ça c'est
incroyable
jusqu'à présent le gouvernement fédéral
et de congrégations religieuses conteste
ce recours collectif m steyn ne s'en
cache pas il souhaite une entente hors
cour
mais ça n'effacera pas des souffrances
de ses clients je veux saluer au passage
bruno roy l'écrivain qui a milité on le
voit dans les images d'archivés
catherine pour ce dossier là et il est
mort il ya huit ans maintenant monsieur
vont apprécier sur le combat d'une vie
oui bon pour appeler catherine que ça a
duré très longtemps là c était les
chiffres et dates qu'on a c'est à peu
près de 1940 à la fin des années 60 et
c'était pas tous des orphelins et
c'était des gens qui dans bien des cas
les parents ne pouvait plus s'en occuper
c'est le cas de madame de madame
gaudreault est justement la mer et est
mort d'un cancer le père a dit qu'est ce
que je fais bon monsieur le curé venu le
voir écoute on va s'occuper de tes
filles et elle a été placée est tout de
suite en partant déclaré finalement
débile mental profonde et toute la
famille également déclaré aussi débile
mental et ce qui était faux et je leur
souligner pour les gens qui sont moins
famille cld aussi si on tenait si le
gouvernement du québec de dupes les
citoyens ce qu'ont les eaux les nomme
des belles ou arriéré c'est qu'en
faisant ça c'était considéré comme un
acte de santé et et qu'on recevait de
l'argent du beurre en faveur du
gouvernement fédéral
il ya eu ce règlement de bernard landry
en 2002 il ya eu un autre règlement 2007
on a ajouté plus de gens voilà
mais eux disent on s'est fait avoir sur
ce sujet voir exactement la somme
maximum qu'il pouvait obtenir c'était 25
mille dollars à peu près parce que en
partance étaient dix mille dollars qu'on
avait fixé plus 1000 $ par année de
l'internement exactement alors le
maximum c'était au tour de 23000 mais on
a décidé à l'époque que c'était
seulement 1100 personnes qui avaient de
quoi à cet argent là et on a mis de côté
tous ceux qui avaient subi des sévices
sexuels même
ce monsieur marc boudreau savais pas
qu'il était un orphelin de duplessis
absolument rien obtenu
madame goudreau absolue 15000 dollars
mais je veux dire c'était sensé quel
moment donné il estime que justice n'a
pas été rendue
et c'est sur la maintenant ils réclament
de l'argent est évidemment le l'avocat
aimerait bien qu' il y ait une entente à
l'amiable
parce que sinon il attend justement la
décision l'addition d'un juge qui
devrait prendre sa décision d'ici la fin
du mois voir si ce recours sera accepté
ou pas parce que sinon aussi c'est
contester si les autorités il n'accepte
pas d'arriver à une entente
ça peut être extrêmement à léon et ces
gens là évidemment sont plus très jeune
oui et il n'y aurait plus que 400
maintenant qui vivrait il était dans les
années 90 au delà de 3000 catherine
kovacs fort intéressant merci beaucoup
n'y a pas de quoi faut revoir